So, the brain is generally
what we're talking about and
here you have a picture,
the overall view of the human brain.
A friend of mine, Jeremy Wolf, always
said make sure you draw in the nose.
So, okay, so your nose is over there,
your eyeballs here and then there
are all these various structures,
the cerebellum in the back here.
Behind your head is where a lot of rapid
motor control kinds of things take
effect, bunch a whole bunch of
structures, all of this crinkly stuff up
here is the cortex and we'll talk
about that a little bit later.
By the way these little things sticking
out right here called the olfactory
bulbs, those are the things that
actually go into your nasal cavity that
does sense of smell, that's actually
a part of your brain that sticks out
into your into your nose.
And another part of your brain that
sticks out is actually your retina and
we'll talk about that in a minute.
The parts of the brain I want to talk
about today are, its, this lesson and
next, of course, are the parts that are
involved with the human vision system.
And those are poorly drawn
here on this schematic.
It's just ugly, but
it's actually much clearer.
So, again, here we your two eyes.
Okay, okay now your nose is up here.
And, you notice that out, coming out of
each eye is what's referred to as the,
an optic nerve, and
they sort of cross in this funny way
at what's referred to as the apt,
the optic chiasm.
They then make, a, a way stop.
They make a stop here, down in here in,
lateral geniculate and
then the lateral ge, which we'll talk
about, and the lateral geniculate
has projections up into something
called the superior colliculus.
And the, most of it, a lot of it goes
to what's called the visual cortex,
and we're going to talk about that.
By the way, we describe these things as
if it's a flow of information going up.
And that's partially because as
computationalists, we like to say, well,
first we do some low-level processing
at the, at the, the detectors and
the retina and then it goes up to
these weigh stations where various
kinds of things happen, and
then up for higher level processing.
The reality is somewhere between 80 and
95% of the projections into,
for example, the lateral geniculate,
are actually from the cortex back down.
So the engineers amongst you will say,
oh,
that's gotta be feedback of some sort.
Well indeed it probably is,
and it's still stuff that we're
just slowly getting a handle on.
So take what I'm about to
say with a grain of salt.
In fact, well, take everything I
ever say with a grain of salt.
But in particular,
I'm only going to give you
a relatively simplistic view of
what's going on in the vision system.
It's also a slightly dated
view because while I'm
try to be pretty current about
certain computer vision things,
there's a massive, massive field of
neurophysiology and human vision.
So I'm just going to give you some
of the highlights and it'll give you
a general overview and I encourage you
to, to read more as we go forward.
One thing to say also before we continue
forward is sort of the anatomy and
physiology of the brain really reflect
the computational complexity of vision.
So to give you an example, you have
auditory nerves that come from your,
cochlea that go into your brain and
those nerves, there's two of them,
one for each ear, and those nerves have
somewhere around 30,000 nerve fibers in,
in that bundle, okay?
The optic nerve, each one coming out
of here, that has somewhere around
a million fibers, okay, 30,000 for
hearing, a million for vision from each.
Likewise, and
we'll talk more about this later.
We are going to talk about the visual
cortex, this area back here.
So far, and that you can,
again, you know, plus or minus,
somewhere around 30% of your cortex,
right?
The cortex being the most recent
part of the brain in terms
evolutionary structures.
We think of it as being
sort of the human helmet.
Somewhere around 30% of the visual,
of the cortex is seen to have something
to do with vision, as opposed to,
say, 3% for hearing and 8% for
all somatic sensory touch.
So, again, the complexity of vision is
not only showing up when you look at
your problem sets and how, and you say,
how could this possibly work, but
it is also reflected in the detail
structure of the human anatomy.